[Music]
the return to ccsd coming up on monday
for hundreds of thousands of students
and teachers and while this new year
promises a fresh start for many some
challenges still linger for our district
that's right today we sat down with
superintendent dr jesus jara ahead of
the first day of school and of course no
topic was off limits from staffing
shortages to school safety
how ready is ccsd for this new school
year well it's it is exciting it's that
time of year you start feeling the
excitement the teachers came back last
thursday the new teachers you know you
start feeling the energy i feel it not
only in the schools in the community we
are ready sounds like the district is
prepared and ready for for monday but
the question obviously so many uh
parents are asking is you know
in terms of staff last night we had our
bids for our bus drivers um to come in
and bid for their routes
um then you know you're gonna be the
first to know um you know when we looked
at our vacancy you know we're down from
250 where we open to 84. right now today
i have to take care of the kids we are
deploying every educator in the central
office onto our schools we are deploying
administrators who have licenses onto
our schools we want a certified educator
licensed in the classroom with kids that
is our priority in terms of violence and
safety very busy school year last year
what is the game plan moving forward for
this new school year we have obviously
all the details are because of safety
measures you know we we are
keeping those close to our our best if
you will um but you know we're
addressing the single point of entry we
are addressing you know the fencing that
we are seeing
um across the in our schools uh we're
updating camera systems right to even
though that's not a uh
i mean it's more of a deterrent but it's
really gives that frame where we we can
um we can use to you know to catch the
bad guys if you will uh and the instant
alert
well the superintendent is not releasing
too many details about safety measures
in our conversations but he did stress
that the district is working closely
with ccsd police and metro police as
usual now coming up at five o'clock we
asked the superintendent about
incentives to get more teachers into the
classrooms and other concerns many
parents have